here's a peek at what guests had to say
after the show Dan Savage you have ever
given sex advice that you now regret
good question of course I have but it's
advice not binding arbitration I write
an advice column I do a sex advice
podcast but just give an example of
something that you had a second thought
about Oh years ago when I was young and
callow and just started I advised me to
get drunk and drive fast because I
didn't like the hall well that's not
even about sex no it's just stupid just
stupid yeah yeah I've gotten better at
this game we all we all have you know
youthful indiscretions okay
Dick Cheney said he spends little time
considering his faults how critical is
introspection to a political career
you're gonna have to handle it John
[Laughter]
well you know I mean George Bush
famously used to say you know that he
was not introspective he was rather
proud of that I never thought that was a
good thing but I sort of also understand
how when you're a politician it's very
hard to be introspective because if you
change your mind any time from eighteen
to sixty they say you're flip-flopping
no all your advisers tell you if you
ever change your mind you'll be attacked
for it right you ever admit an error
you'll be attacked for it I was at
disappointed when Bush in the 2004
election was asked if he had made any
mistakes and he couldn't think of one
this in 2000 2004 and when I thought I
mean I think of three things every night
before I fall asleep that I could have
done better that I did wrong that was a
mistake
I fallen asleep without coming up with
Rica's I was tired but I've never sat
there wondering could not couldn't think
of any mistakes you had for years
without thinking well we are so on the
same page on that over because whenever
I hear people in interviews and they say
this all the time they're asked any
regrets and they go no regrets George
Zimmerman said that they said do you
regret
I mean how easy is to say yeah I really
do regret that was really ended badly no
he said it was God's plan really I'm
wondering about my decision to come here
today somebody should it's true in
politics if you change your position
you're dead I mean it's it's the hue
hell to pay for I mean all John Kerry
said when he said that thing about I
would vote it for it revival I was
against it for what he meant to say and
he could have saved himself a lot of
problems was by saying the bill changed
I was for the bill the way they first
wrote it and then I was against it the
way they wrote the second time but you
know there's a great great leader in
Israel that changed his mind and came
out public it's hack robbing and he said
sure I cremini said I don't I didn't
believe in negotiating with the
Palestinian and giving them land now I
believe in that because this is best for
my Sharona mine is rayul Sharon Cohen
was a huge hardline there anything guess
what that's all
they take away Jews are smart Connie
Mack as a former member of the
Congressional Cuba democracy caucus when
will US citizens be able to travel to
Cuba well I might you know look we don't
want to put more money in the hands of
the Fidel Castro brothers I mean look we
have you been there have you been there
no yeah it's not legal I'm not no it's
uh it's everything that goes into Cuba
goes into the Castro pockets oh come on
it's true how come Americans were
allowed to travel into the Soviet Union
at the height of the Cold War as
tourists money into China why is it
worked for China not Cuba I would agree
that our foreign policy has a lot of
problems including when the President of
the United States Barack Obama says in
Honduras when the military removed the
president of Honduras because he wanted
to change the constitution against the
Constitution he was quick to say it was
a military coup in Egypt when the
military goes in and removes the
president of Egypt he doesn't call it a
military coup well we know why he didn't
do that because it was money because if
he called it a coup then we couldn't
give Egypt aid and if we can't give
Egypt aid they can't go and turn around
and give that money to General Dynamics
oh well but we'll run over a small
little country and but don't you think
if we had not had an embargo for the
last 50 years Cuba right now would be
more like st. Barts no no I think if it
wasn't for Chavez helping Cuba Chavez
yeah Hugo Chavez remember that guy yeah
but all the money and gas too last year
yeah Chavez wasn't on the scene for the
except for the last ten years I mean
what about their 20th century they've
got some real economic problems
okay on the first anniversary of the
Aurora theater shootings any suggestions
on new ways to talk about gun control -
the momentum that is building for gun
reform I haven't noticed that picks up
speed as it did with marriage equality
Wow if this person thinks that we're
gonna change on guns the way that we did
on gays they're crazy
I know gays we could move on guns come
on we're not understand about opposition
to background checks and closing the gun
show loophole is you would think the
people most invested in keeping guns out
of the hands of lunatics would be
supporters of the Second Amendment and
people who want to own their guns
nothing imperils the Second Amended more
than some jackass like the Aurora
theater shooter getting his hands on
guns or the guy who shot up that
elementary school and so if we had if
this bar was set higher to own a gun it
would make being a gun owner a more
privileged and sort of honored position
just like throwing guns out the windows
of gun shops to any [ __ ] who walks by
is actually in the long run gonna one
day undo the Second Amendment you would
think that the NRA would be anxious to
close the gun show loophole I don't at
least as onerous as a driver's license I
don't to have any of that stuff I don't
want the federal go
the fact that they're collecting all of
this data on now that they're spying on
Americans that they're using the Patriot
Act for their own own for the
government's advantage you on the rock
Congress when george w bush was yes he
was I voted against that bill yes that
needs to be discussed in public you're
so right about it
let's do what England did you know they
had this debate security versus privacy
and this debate went in the parliament
and they voted against it I think we
should bring this debate out and vote
eventually Pro are against it but the
gun thing it's a huge different issue
I hope you're as consistent on that like
privacy I am like that's why I say I
don't want to have a race for the gun I
can vouch for this man he is consistent
on this issue and Jimmy Carter was in
Germany yesterday yes and he said this
is no longer really a functioning
democracy because
our privacy has gone out the window and
he said we owe Snowden a great debt
would you agree with that I look I don't
I'm not getting in the business of
calling him a hero or a traitor but I am
glad that the the American the public is
seeing what is happening in the federal
government and seeing the data that is
being collected on everyone if you look
at the facility that's being built in in
Utah it's it's able to hold a thousand
years of all of the data that has
already been collected around the world
I mean this this should frighten
everybody that the federal government
has this type of you know there's no way
that the federal government should have
this type of information it'll only be
used to manipulate and intimidate people
and I don't think it's a good thing it's
a slippery slope that they will cross
it's at some point I mean the thing is
that they really haven't done anything
with it so far that has made people
outraged but what happened that we're
off that we know of right but what
happens the first time somebody says you
know we're only supposed to use this
information to catch terrorists but we
just saw something about a child
molester can we use it now who's gonna
stand up and say no you can't use it for
against the child first conviction using
the powers of the Patriot Act with some
strip club in Las Vegas right the powers
of the Patriot I remember not limited to
going after terrorism when when we had
this discussion and they were putting it
forward that list in the Patriot Act is
all this stuff that Clinton put forward
after the Oklahoma bombing and he said
we need all these powers he didn't the
guys the process writers in the Justice
Department ready with the with the stack
of papers and the Republicans in
Congress said you've got to be kidding
me we're not giving any any president
these powers when Bush did it that was
their first reaction to and they they
got overwhelmed and Daschle in the
Senate made all the DS vote for it as
well as it it got pushed through there
was an effort to do triage this is
ridiculous we're not doing it this we
could live with if it's just terrorism
and this is a good idea why didn't we
think of this before but instead they
just passed the whole thing and they
didn't have some sort of sunset which i
think is what they should have done that
sunset for a few things thank you
everybody thank you thank you
audience real time with bill maher
Friday night at 10:00 passed bill and
his guests to her questions right after
the show at hbo.com